I guess it is pretty green to me it's
not it wasn't just always all green now
I'm quite green
[Music]
my name is Elizabeth sweetheart
and I am the green lady
[Music]
everything is green I brought green
counter and then I got green knobs and
then all the accessories we even painted
the front door green if I find something
that I really like in terms of clothing
and what I wear I make it green these
are my overalls I grew up with my family
in Nova Scotia and they didn't know what
to do with me I wanted to be an artist I
started wearing green and my dad invited
me to visit Florida it was really
exciting for me to go because we hadn't
really connected and he didn't really
care for an artist the water is aqua
green deep rich Green's
I painted all the palm trees and from
that point on I started adding little
bits of green because it was like a
lucky day that dad asked me to go visit
it's been around 17 to 20 years I
continue to wear green because the way I
dress makes other people smile and say
oh the green lady can I have a selfie
with you
I think people really really like the
belief that you like something enough to
really carry it through when you're
young you tend to think you look good in
black
as you get older you realize color is so
much fun I will continue to be green
because it's so positive I think when
it's not them I'll change to my next
favorite thing
New York's a tough city to live it it
always has been
okay the old saying if you can make it
here you can make it anywhere I think
because the birds have made it here
I mean they've endured this far my name
is Steve Baldwin and I've been tracking
the wild parents of Brooklyn for about
ten years now those two looks sort of
frisky it's not really that mating
season but my upset of Monaco's the monk
parakeet
native to Argentina and as far as we
know something happened at Kennedy
Airport in 1967 or 1968 it appears that
a crate full of parrots arrived from
Argentina something went wrong a bunch
of them escaped they came to Brooklyn
College right here we've got an
incredible cast of parrots here today
one two three four they're smaller than
it than a pigeon but larger than a
sparrow then the only kind of parents
that build these freestanding structures
these nests can get up to the size of
small cars it's methodical work its twig
after twig after twig parrots are sort
of the primates of the bird world
they're smart they're communicative they
eat almost anything that's available to
them so they're perfectly set up really
to thrive in a place like Brooklyn even
though it's not where they came from
they've adapted extremely well you have
to I think have a certain fiber of Steel
that to make it in this town and I think
the parrots have those qualities
[Music]
this is what a typical bodegas sounds
like but this bodega sounds a little
different almost every street corner in
New York City has a small store with
sandwiches groceries and drinks this is
a bodega
so your money one day's a one second
shondo okay
Jonas is a pub little mini Khanna yo
evil is a tuna they value yo seh mi
guitarra tell you quiero ser tu mam
mudha know why you're working in no vent
I know Evan Bourne and pasilla radio GSN
Quattron you know any good a bodega
Kayoko no Katanga radio como yo aquí la
bodega just what your money well this
guy automatic comment ain't rollin radio
SD a yoga master Elam Bo Colombian upon
abre
okay almost this is working coke 80 are
cocaine po is a come on nombre de
colombia fame and fortune as you know
Colombia to come the anomaly me show
they represent a la comunidad Latino are
keying in Brooklyn in New York the demo
L can say mas o menos de Cuarenta melee
assassin Tammy personas trato de compras
a rotary tampoco con a con su musica una
musica Luana
una musica Romantica merengue bachata
Tata musica classica en todo de CD todo
trello una sola radio her Lambie FM a
llamo a mass in focus on o solamente
musica tup show involucre dhokala
comunidad is new york mucho tiempo trois
Erin area mula mala yo que vamos a bit
Imola gente the couch on radio a la
reunión comunitaria in tratar de
irregular lo problema que tenemos a king
record Alec a cualquier cualquier in ta
- t OT Tenga es muy importante que usted
hace Tala reuniones gracias a la gente
el presento so tempe cinco y in
comunidad en en conjunto kono so
tratamos en un trabajo es bastante la la
polio que estamos teniendo la comunidad
de la walking down this quiet street in
Brooklyn you'd never know that inside
this building within this tiny apartment
the music is made
meet Evan and Luke there are longtime
friends and roommates Evan and I have
been living together here for how many
years I believe the other man and a half
and once a month in only about five
hundred square feet they managed to pile
in up to sixty musicians for the
ultimate recording session bridge
arrangement we record it in about three
hours and post it online a lot of
people's reactions are that it seems
crazy and it is crazy to pull this off
first they have to uproot their humble
abode
anything that is not involved in making
music has to go we take all the
furniture out
okay take most of the doors off it's
just all about making as much room as
much sightlines as possible it really
just looks like chaos there's mic stands
everywhere the floor is littered with
musics anthem I'm a little worried about
this though there's not a single inch to
spare and that's because they make way
for the strings woodwinds horns
percussion and a full choir yeah that's
a marimba in the kitchen why I wanted an
opportunity to record a bunch of people
at the same time
Luke learn an opportunity to hear his
Arrangements play so we just invited a
bunch of people over and although it
seems unconventional there's a reason
for the madness we're trying to change
the way that you might see an orchestra
play there is a special dynamic and a
feeling in the room that you won't get
in a recording studio or in a public
venue it's this unique sound and sense
of community that it's attractive
musicians from all over the country to
participate
there's definitely something really
exciting about the idea that this
shouldn't really be possible it's a
really unique experience and I think
that people are drawn to that and so
they keep at it
[Music]
it's a real kind of jarring wonderful
experience every time and we love it
and I bet the neighbors must love it too
they're lucky they're good
[Applause]
you get your hair done you can't be
touched
you're just you're on point for at least
48 hours the queer community needs a
safe space to get haircuts and that's
part of the reason why I'm here
my name is des Marshall I'm a barber I
work in Brooklyn New York
the barber shop I work at it's called
the gamesman it's kind of an institution
here in downtown Brooklyn the owner
Frank has been here for over 50 years
the clientele has been a lot of men who
working in the neighborhood it's a lot
of lawyers a lot of judges other types
of businessmen I kind of throw a wrench
in Soho that I mix it up a little bit my
clientele is mostly queer trans gender
non-conforming folks of color non folks
of color for the most part my clientele
is the LGBTQ community I think with
barbershops it's difficult as a woman to
walk in the can sometimes just feel like
a boys club it's nice to feel like you
can let your hair down or get it off
I think I'm building a bridge in
different ways can you be at 5:00 3:30 I
got you for queer folks the trans folks
are gender non-conforming folks hair is
very important you keep it really crisp
or more rounded got you but you need a
barber that you feel comfortable to talk
to about how you want to look what's
that vision that you have someone who
can execute it but also do it in a way
that they're not gonna be judging you
throughout the whole process
I get to spend my day with other queer
folks in a space that you know twenty
years ago we probably couldn't even walk
walked into you know I'm part of that
story now my clients are part of that
story now we're part of the history of
this place we're part of its legacy and
that's it's really cool
you